[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à bruxelles j moins
65 avant les élections européennes et
nous poursuivons cette semaine notre
tour d'europe dans cette édition
direction la grèce qui est sorti l'été
dernier des programmes dead et de la
tutelle de ses créanciers aujourd'hui le
pays se porte mieux mais après huit
années d'austérité
c'est une population parfois désabusé
qui aborde ce scrutin européen syriza le
parti issu de la gauche radicale porté
au pouvoir il ya quatre ans est en perte
de vitesse au profit des conservateurs
nous le verrons dans notre reportage à
suivre et nous en discuterons avec nos
invités
mais je vous propose d'abord de nous
arrêter sur les grands sujets qui ont
fait l'actualité européenne des derniers
jours avec aurélie d'afas
[Musique]
le breakbeat aura-t-il bien lieu le 29
mars prochain à moins d'un mois de la
date du divorce
les députés britanniques ont donné leur
accord pour repousser la sortie du
royaume uni de l'union européenne un
report qui ne serait pas sans
conséquence
alors que les élections européennes
doivent se tenir le 26 mai prochain
un report important de la date du brics
il exigerait que le royaume uni prennent
part au processus électoral
une complication supplémentaire en
perspective pour européens et
britanniques arrivés en tête au premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle
susanna caputo va est pratiquement
assurée de devenir la première femme
chef de l'état slovaque 7 libéral a pris
position pour l'accès à libé g et des
droits élargis pour les couples
homosexuels
quand son principal opposant souligné
son attachement aux valeurs chrétiennes
elle est crédité de 65 % des intentions
de vote pour le second tour
une percée libéral notable en europe de
l'est propos intolérables indigne le
président du parlement européen a
déclenché un tollé en évoquant mussolini
à la radio italienne antonio tajani a
déclaré on peut ne pas partager sa
méthode mais il faut être honnête
mussolini a fait des routes des ponts
ajoutant je ne considère pas son action
au gouvernement comme positive mais il y
a des choses qui ont été faites
les réactions des groupes politiques de
tous bords n'ont pas tardé allant
jusqu'à réclamer sa démission
je demande au président du parlement
pour attirer donc retiré cette
déclaration sinon antonio tajani a dû
présenter ses excuses dans un communiqué
et pour tenter d'analyser cette
polémique j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
sur ce plateau il y aurait kuczkiewicz
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le chef du
service monde et spécialiste des
questions européennes pour le quotidien
belge le soir
alors on l'a vu un ses propos très
à ces propos du président du parlement
européen ont entraîné de très vives
réactions à votre avis qu'est ce qui a
pu amener antonio tajani à tenir ces
propos
moi je crois je crois que c'est pas la
première fois que présidente annie à des
propos un peu étonnant un peu à la
limite du révisionnisme historique
il a fait sur l'estrie la dalmatie donc
l'ex yougoslavie
c'est la deuxième polémique voila voila
il a eu des propos aussi sur les roms
y'a pas longtemps en oubliant sur les
rom italien en oubliant que ce sont que
les roms italiens sont des citoyens
italiens qui risque d'accaparer trop de
deux subventions sociales
moi je dirais je ne connais pas assez
bien mais je pense qu'on dirait que le
naturel remonte un petit peu par
accident
chez le président tagliani avec des
idées ou des réminiscences qui vive a
quand même toujours dans le subconscient
d'une partie de la société italienne
comme d'ailleurs c'est le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres sociétés
alors c'est totalement déplacé je dirais
c'est même idiot insensé pour un
président italien de dire des choses
pareilles sur moss mussolini
factuellement il dit vrai mussolini
comme hitler et fait des choses n'ont
pas seulement mis des gens en prison
mais malgré tout l'essentiel de leurs
actions contre ça a été de mener des
dictats de de gérer des dictatures
d'installer une dictature de poursuivre
les juifs les opposants etc etc
donc pour un président du parlement
européen de dire ça c'est totalement
insensé déplacés moi je n'ai qu'une
qu'un commentaire je pense que le
naturel remonte un petit peu au galop
ché ché ché le président tajani alors
vous en parliez un mi février à trieste
il a déclaré vive l'istrie et la
dalmatie italienne mais ces régions sont
croates et non plus italienne ces propos
ont donc aussi beaucoup choqué on sait
que c'est un peu un cheval de bataille
sa de la droite berlusconienne comme
sujet c'est la droite italienne qui
flatte qui flatte par moments
l'électorat centriste mais qui par
moments flat et peut-être plus
naturellement plus spontanément flat
l'électorat plus révisionniste plus
revanchiste revanchard etc
quel est le rôle du président du
parlement européen on connaît pas
forcément très bien cette fonction
dans le cas du parlement européen je
dirais que la fonction
des ponts pas mal de la personnalité de
celui qu'il occupe ou bien on a connu
deux présidents qui gère qui gère qui
assure je dirais le maintien et qui font
avancer sans trop de heurts le parlement
en assurant la gestion politique qui
consiste surtout et bien à concilier les
points de vue
parce que tant administrative ou
politique c'est un petit peu de deux
administratives et parce que c'est quand
même la gestion d'une très grosse
institution et c'est également politique
mais là sur l'aspect politique ça dépend
des personnalités par exemple le
prédécesseur le prédécesseur de
d'antonio tajani martin schulz lui il a
donné il a donné un profil très
politique très personnelle
il était très critiqué pour ça au
parlement même par ses propres troupes
il a donné une fonction très politique à
cette fonction là tajani ville est
beaucoup plus dans les arrangements je
dirais ce qu'ils n'empêchent pas quand
même d'avoir des sorties mais qui pour
le coup sont totalement à côté de la
plaque en dans le président du parlement
européen un mandat de président du
parlement européen ces deux ans et demi
celui d'antonio tajani est bientôt
terminée qu'elle son bilan vous en
parler un petit peu mais le bilan je
dirais il est relativement relativement
insignifiant relativement insignifiant
voilà il a tenu la boutique
il a tenu la boutique sans trop de
heurts à l'intérieur ce qui n'était pas
le cas de martin schulz qui était
politiquement beaucoup plus critiqué
mais qui prenait des décisions parfois
essayé d'imposer des décisions tranchées
dans l'organisation dans le
fonctionnement du parlement européen
tajani a été beaucoup plus je dirais
auront là dessus comme beaucoup comme le
font en général les présidents de
parlement européen alors revenons
maintenant sur ce premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle en slovaquie
et cette percée du novice en politique
qui se présente comme une candidate anti
corruption
écoutez la il pose manu d'un sommet
jeunes on dirait que les électeurs et
les électrices levac c peuvent
s'imaginer que quelqu'un qui n'a pas
beaucoup d'expérience politique peut
amener une vision nouvelle de la réalité
ainsi que différentes solutions pour
régler les problèmes
résultats sont un signal pour moi qu'il
y a un besoin de changement
un besoin de changement est ce qu elle a
bénéficié vous pensez de l'élan provoqué
par la mort du journaliste
il ya un coup de sac et de sa compagne
je rappelle que journaliste il enquêtait
sur les liens entre la mafia et le
gouvernement
oui certainement certainement ce qui est
intéressant dans dans ce cas là est ce
qu exemple atik je dirais dedans de la
slovaquie à l'échelle de la région de
l'europe centrale et de l'europe
orientale
ce qu'on ignore souvent en occident dans
nos pays si en france en belgique etc
c'est que pour l'instant actuellement
ces pays là sont souvent dirigées par
des gouvernements des partis ou des
régimes critique et populiste populiste
de droite voire populiste de gauche
comme c'est le cas du parti dominant en
slovaquie le maire qui est affiliée à la
famille socialiste
mais ce qu'on ignore souvent c'est que
dans ces sociétés là il y a en général
un électorat assez compact assez solide
qui est qui a disons qu'ils se laissent
emporter par les slogans populistes et
qui suit les les partis qui trônait
pouvoir fort un petit peu et libéraux
comme le divx urbain par exemple comme
il le fait en hongrie mais il y a un
fort électorat qui est susceptible et on
le voit justement ici avec cette
élection présidentielle de voter pour
quelqu'un qui est plus modéré plus
ouvert sur le monde sur la coopération
est plus pro européen et son adversaire
1 au deuxième tour ce sera maros
sefcovic ans est l'actuel vice-président
de la commission qui actuellement disons
qui a pris congé de cette fonction là
voilà qui est je dirais le un visage
respectable d'un parti populiste de
gauche membre de la famille socialiste
européenne qui n'a pas vraiment a des
raisons d'en être fier mais qui est lui
un visage respectable
derrière lui c'est un parti affairistes
qui semble mouillé dans dans des
affaires louches probablement impliquées
directement ou indirectement dans
l'assassinât de ce journaliste en tout
cas peut-être une femme bientôt à la
tête de la slovaquie on suivra ça
attentivement le 30 mars merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité aujourd'hui
placement
non à la suite de notre tour d'europe
avec un détour par le sud
direction la grèce un pays de près de 11
millions d'habitants dont le poids
économique représente 1,41 pour cent du
pib de l'union européenne la grèce est
un état membre depuis 1981 et elle
compte 21 députés au parlement européen
à sa tête un président de la république
issu des rangs du parti conservateur
nouvelle démocratie mais son rôle n'est
que représentatif à athènes le pouvoir
est entre les mains d'alexis presse le
premier ministre chef de file du parti
syriza au départ un parti anti système
dont la ligne est devenu moins radicale
au fil du temps notre reporter est allé
à la rencontre de ces grecs qui semblent
plus préoccupés par les élections
législatives qui auront lieu après l'été
que par le scrutin européen voyez ce
reportage
il est signé jérôme radiés
[Musique]
la grèce relève doucement la tête après
des années d'austérité les plans
drastiques des créanciers comme l'union
européenne et le fmi sont désormais
derrière le pays
le premier ministre alexis tsipras ce la
firme une page se tourne pour les
salariés du bas de l'échelle comme
apostolos secours coup tu as les
dernières mesures du gouvernement sont
une petite bouffée d'oxygène employé
d'une multinationale de location de
voitures il est payé au salaire minimum
qui vient d'être augmenté de 11 % au 1er
février
j'ai commencé en 2017 avec le salaire
minimum qui était à l'époque de 586
euros brut
je touche 650 euros bruts à c'est pour
vivre dignement sans devoir de l'argent
à quelqu'un d'autre va devoir emprunter
de l'argent à la fin du mois et c'est
aussi assez pour espérer que dans le
futur les jours meilleurs on revenir à
33 ans ce militant du mouvement syriza
du premier ministre alexis tsipras ce
vit seule dans un appartement familial
où depuis 2011
les chauffages d'appoint ont remplacé
les radiateurs mureaux le fuel étant
devenu inabordable pour les faire
fonctionner il espère que les élections
européennes permettront de faire
entendre la voix des pays d'europe du
sud frappé par la crise je considère que
syriza aujourd'hui tant en grèce qu'en
europe a une position très importante
car il peut créer des alliances avec des
forces progressistes notamment les pays
du sud eux aussi économiquement mouche
petit à petit comment portugal en ce
moment où peu demos en espagne je crois
que syriza a beaucoup à offrir et des
batailles à mener sur le chemin de la
démocratie
pour donner une impulsion aux puissances
démocratiques à travers l'europe
comme si le pays va mieux
sur la place syntagma qui a vécu les
plus grandes manifestations contre
l'austérité
les mobilisations restent fréquentes
comme ses professeurs dénonçant le
manque de moyens dans l'éducation
si une majorité de grecs veulent rester
dans l'union européenne dans les rues
d'athènes
beaucoup espèrent un changement de cap
il faut que la politique soit remise au
centre du jeu européen que ce soit
vraiment le rôle essentiel dans la
pratique européenne que l'union cesse de
fonctionner comme un organisme
bureaucratique en faveur d'une minorité
mais qu'elle soit vraiment en faveur du
plus grand nombre
je ne suis pas du tout informé et je ne
sais même pas qui sont les candidats aux
européennes même si je considère qu'il
est très important que nous soyons
représentés au niveau européen car dans
les faits c'est l'union européenne sous
nous définit faut presque notre
gouvernement mais je ne crois pas qu'il
y ait une véritable information sur ce
sujet on doit être dans l'union
européenne
si on se retrouve isolé on va pas
pouvoir survivre
si la campagne des européennes n'a pas
vraiment démarré
c'est que le scrutin passe au second
plan tous les regards est en tournée
vers les élections législatives prévues
après l'été alexis tsipras ci remettra
en jeu son poste de premier ministre
et pour l'instant il est donnée
nettement battu le favori c'est le parti
de droite nouvelle démocratie membres au
niveau européen du ppe aux côtés des
républicains français ou de la cd ou
d'angela merkel pour eux il faut cesser
cette parenthèse de type race qui a
isolé la grèce sur le plan européen
vous venez de ce déguisement
la grèce a été le premier pays à
succomber au populisme quand nous avons
élu un gouvernement syriza alexis
tsipras ce je crois qu'on sera le
premier pays à divorcer du populisme
nous allons retourner au réalisme
judo les avait joués évidemment cela ne
veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas fait des
erreurs dans le passé il faut revenir
aux fondamentaux
nous avons besoin d'un autre modèle
politique économique qui sera basée sur
les meilleures pratiques européennes
confronté aux réalités du pouvoir
alexis tsipras c'est syriza sont passés
d'une position d'extrême gauche à un
programme plus traditionnel des partis
de gauche européens
un recentrage qui risque cependant de ne
pas suffire pour reconquérir les grecs
en quête de normalité pour cet
éditorialiste star en grèce c'est vrai
que si prince est là et la portée de
visibilité à la grèce et la visibilité
de la curiosité avant chance de voir
comment un jeune type radical peut
arriver au pouvoir survivre vous pouvoir
et je vivre dans le cadre de l'union
européenne je crois qu'il est beaucoup
plus apprécié elle projette en grève ont
lieu rue beaucoup plus de crédit à
l'étranger qu'en grèce plongée sous les
feux des projecteurs pendant la crise
économique
puis lors de la crise migratoire les 10
millions de grecs majoritairement
attachées à l'union européenne se
prononceront surtout sur les enjeux
économiques intérieurs
avec l'espoir de tourner la page de ses
années d'austérité
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau wolf klinz
bonjour bonjour vous êtes allemands
membres de la ldj et la formation
centriste et libérale dans ce parlement
européen et vous étiez le président de
la commission spéciale sur la crise
financière
face à vous aujourd'hui marie christine
vergiat bonjour bonjour vous êtes
française membre du front de gauche et
du groupe de la gauche unitaire
européenne dans ce parlement européen
c'est aussi la formation de syriza le
parti d'aller sous presse
et pour compléter ce plateau j'ai le
plaisir de recevoir isabelle thomas
bonjour là bonjour vous êtes également
française membre de génération et du
groupe des socialistes et démocrates
dans ce parlement européen alors on l'a
vu dans ce reportage ces grecs qui
semblent peu intéressés par le scrutin
européen mais qu'il estime qu'il est
important de faire partie de l'union
européenne comment on explique ce
sentiment il appelle thomas et bien je
crois que les premiers à avoir compris
l'importance de l'union dans sa
gouvernance économique ce sont
effectivement les grecs
c'est là qu'ils se sont rendus compte
que il avait perdu finalement le pouvoir
de décider puisque malgré les
référendums 2015
ils ont malgré tout et les référendums
qui refusaient mémorandum
ils ont dû malgré tout appliquer les
décisions de bruxelles donc sans doute
plus difficile encore plus difficile
il s'avère qu'ils ont bien compris donc
que c'était là que ça se passait et pour
autant nous n'avons pas mis en place ici
au sein de l'union européenne
les instances suffisamment démocratique
de la d2 la gouvernance économique qui
s'impose alors on a en effet une
population épuisée par huit ans
d'austérité je rappelle qu entre 2010 et
2018 ça grèce a reçu 260 milliards
d'euros de ses créanciers c'est à dire
l'union européenne le fmi et la bce en
échange évidemment d'importantes coupes
budgétaires est ce que vous pensez
wolf klinz que c'est aussi ce qui a
éloigné finalement les grecs du
sentiment européen des institutions
européennes certes hama cette phase
d'austérité était difficile pour les
citoyens
ils ont beaucoup souffert et ça explique
peut-être l'intérêt en ce qui concerne
les affaires européennes est plus basse
aujourd'hui plus petit qu auparavant
mais je crois que la raison principale
pour
l'intérêt modeste si je peux dire pour
les européennes c'est surtout quand
pratiquement en même temps il y à des
législatives en grèce
mm et c'est une mini sont quand même
épuisé par cette hausse tient plus c'est
certain mais je crois aussi qu'il
respecte il accepte plutôt que
finalement l'europe a donné un signal au
reste du monde que la grèce fait partie
de l'europe et fera partie de l'europe
on laisse pas tomber la grèce en tant
que membre de l'union européenne et en
tant que membre de l'eurozone alors
marie christine vergiat on voit que dans
ce reportage aussi que syriza est en
perte de vitesse dans les sondages alors
que la victoire de ce parti avait étonné
tout le monde y avait aussi montré un
que les grèves voulait en finir avec
l'austérité comment vous l'expliquez
cette perte de popularité
je voudrais d'abord dire que sur issa
est encore à 24 25 % dans les sondages
ce qui pour un parti de la gauche
radicale est quand même un très bon
niveau et qu'il est seulement 5%
derrière néo-démocrate hier le parti de
la droite européenne
je voudrais aussi rappeler comment on en
est arrivé là on en est arrivé là parce
qu'en 2009 le gouvernement de monsieur
gbagbo a dévoilé que la dette grecque
avait été maquillé évoquant democracia
il faut quand même le dire ça parce que
je pense qu'il faut rappeler salah le
baril en cette ère nouvelle
celui qui est en tête des sondages
aujourd'hui s'il ya eu trois plans
d'austérité c'est à cause de ces gens là
qui ont joué avec l'argent des grecs et
les grecs l'ont payé très cher
très très cher et notamment les
catégories les plus modestes 1 et moi je
me félicite que depuis un an un an et
demi
la grèce s'est retrouvé une certaine
marge de manoeuvre est que cette marge
de manoeuvre s'est dit dans le reportage
aussi est allé au pad aux catégories de
la population les plus en difficulté on
y entraîne encore très très loin de ce
qu'il faudrait faire et c'est cela que
avec site free press
risque de payer mais quand il testé dans
son client en tout cas sa popularité
baisse pourquoi il faut rappeler aussi
qu'en 2015 quand ce gouvernement de
gauche radicale est arrivé au pouvoir
un certain jean-claude rue john kerr a
expliqué que la démocratie devait se
faire dans le cadre des traités
européens parce que monsieur qui passe à
essayer une autre solution mais il n'a
pas eu le choix
l'union européenne les ministres de
l'économie et des finances de la zone
euro l'ont enfoncée et l'ont empêché de
faire un choix alternatif
le pôle important franchement c'est pas
la popularité ou pas de monsieur si
prince le plus important c est ce que
les mesures économiques qui ont été
prises par l'union européenne dans les
années 2014 2015 2000 et c est ce que
ses choix économiques ont été les bons
et est-ce qu effectivement ce qu'on nous
raconte sur le fait que ça va mieux en
grèce est ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce
que c'est pas vrai moi de mon point de
vue c'est pas vrai parce que quand on a
perdu l'arrêt de même un chômage qui est
resté en dessous de la barre des 20 pour
ça qu on a perdu un pied un tiers du
pib' un tiers du people car depuis un
quart du pipe on a perdu un tiers des
salaires des revues des salariés donc on
est dans une situation dramatique en
grèce et est-ce que et la dette pour le
moins que j'aurais à 104 toujours à 180%
la réalité économique de la grèce
elle est encore aujourd'hui maquillée
excusez moi de le dire elle est
idéologiquement maquiller parce qu'on
veut faire croire pardonnez moi de dire
que les mesures de saigner à l'image des
médecins de molière
les mesures de saignée qui ont été
imposées à la grèce ont été finalement
positive je ne crois pas que je pense
que ce que vous venez de dire moi aussi
je crois que
le drame si je peux dire grecque n'est
pas encore terminée parce que la
situation actuelle c'est quoi ce sens
80% de dettes du pipe 1 191 et on dit la
grèce a été sauvée au début de la crise
de la dette et 132 % de son ca augmenter
et sam l'effondrement du pib a augmenté
lui de voir s'il n'a pas eu de
croissance tombe à cause du fait qu'il
n'a pas eu de croissance mât peuvent
plus dans une crise des dépositions
nouvel épisode est donc si maintenant
les intérêts commencent à augmenter un
de ces jours ça va être le cas et gilles
à crans la croissance ne peuvent
vraiment excessive
à ce moment là la grèce se trouvera dû
de nouveau dans une crise primo d'air
donc moi je crois on a fait une une
il alla au commencement en aurait dû
faire ce que les les règles du traité de
maastricht ne manque à savoir accepter
que la grèce doit se déclarer en
faillite
tout simplement non non et donc le démon
alors j'ai que vous ne venez pas celle
là
la logique du à l'europe enfin la raison
d'être de l'europe de l'union européenne
c'est la solidarité
on aurait pensé la raison d'être
s'il n'y a pas de solidarité a plus
d'union européenne n'a pas été celui ci
on avait fusionné ce que nous proposons
si on avait fusionné les dettes en tout
cas partie de la dette qui est dit qu
supérieur aux passants comme ça et que
on est portée sociale écoutez le pipe de
la grèce c'est 2% du pib européen
d'accord c'est comme si c'était une
région moi je prends je prends l'exemple
de la france si on avait une région en
france qu'ils soient en grande
difficulté la moindre des choses ça
serait qu' il ya la solidarité nationale
s'exprime pour l'union rappelle il faut
qu'on fasse la même chose on aurait dit
tout ça m'en dire la grèce n'est plus
capable de nous en informer
mérite mais en même voté au
remboursement
en même temps on est des banques
allemandes
les banques françaises auraient perdu
beaucoup d'argent ça s'est un peu ils
ont ils ont tenté j'ai l'argent je
voudrais qu'on vient de faire une image
symbolique un alexis presse félicité par
angela merkel lors de sa visite en grèce
c'était donc début janvier ce sont
finalement deux ennemis d'hier qui sont
maintenant qui semble en tout cas proche
votre réaction je ne crois pas que c'est
là là le rôle de la chancellière de
supporter un des deux candidats un
séparateur moi je trouve c'est très
révélateur ses félicitations c'est c'est
en quelque sorte la patronne de l'union
européenne qui vient féliciter le petit
prince pour avoir bien appliqué le
mémorandum moi je veux pas vrai ça si
c'est vrai nom c'est ce qui c'est et je
pense qu'il y avait effectivement une
espèce de voilà on vient féliciter les
bonnes élèves qui a détecté félicité ses
adversaires la gauche ce qui le dira
c'est par rapport à la crise
macédonienne on va revenir là-dessus
justement l'action d'alexis presse
elle a aussi été salué pour cet accord
trouvé sur le nom de la macédoine
c'était une querelle diplomatique
vieille de 30 ans de la grèce refusé ce
nom à son voisin slave
mais avec cet accord qui le rebaptise
macédoine du nord la grèce ouvre la voie
pour ce pays à l'adhésion à l'otan
le premier ministre grec a été félicité
par le chef de l'otan le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale américaine et angela
merkel lors de sa visite en janvier
finalement marie christine vergiat c'est
aussi autant d'institutions et de
personnes qui étaient décriées en par ce
parti par l'ultra gauche avant - les
félicitations de l'auteur m'intéresse
pas beaucoup entre nous
ça ouvre aussi la voie de l'adhésion de
la macédoine à l'union européenne
puisque c'était impossible de faire
rentrer des états qui n'était pas qui
était en guerre politique si je peux
dire
et moi je me félicite qu'il y ait un
accord qui soit trouvée c'est un peu
c'est des relents de nationalisme un peu
différent de ce qu'on peut vivre en
france ou en allemagne
un qui pense au dessin de la carte de la
macédoine si cette notion a un sens au
moment d'alexandre le grand
parce que c'est ça le sujet les grecs
veulent garder alexandre le grand dans
leurs pattes ils dans leurs pattes
éloigné du cours du brent
soyons sérieux quand même l avantage
c'est que vraiment c'est ce compromis
est dans l'intérêt de l'union européenne
a aussi de l'otan par ailleurs que
maintenant ça ou ça ou de l'adresse bien
sûr ça ouvre le chemin de la macédonie
du nord de s'intégrer et éventuellement
dans l'union européenne et russie de
l'autre
en tout cas sur la question de la
macédoine ans alexis presse n'a pas
hésité à aller contre l'opinion et gris
café c'est ce que je voulais dire parce
que moi je me félicite aussi de 2,7 de
cette décision et de la manière dont ça
a été négocié et je trouve là pour le
coup qu'avec ses petits bras ça a été
extrêmement courageux parce que il est
vrai qu'il est allé à l'encontre d'une
partie pas tout l'opinion publique mais
d'une partie de l'opinion publique dont
les relents nationalistes ne sont pas
pour le coup à démontrer et là pour le
coup je trouve que c'est vraiment un
acte de courage tout à fait remarquable
est à saluer moi je voudrais maintenant
un conte termine sur l'autre dossier qui
touche la grèce directement 1 c'est
évidemment la migration à la grèce qui
est en première ligne face aux flux
migratoires et qui réclame comme
l'italie plus de solidarité
parmi les états membres mais ça semble
très très compliqué vous pensez que
c'est aussi ce qu'il éloigne les grecs
de l'union européenne à maritima je ne
sais pas si ça éloigne les règles de
l'union européenne parce que ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que la grèce est le
pays qui a été le plus touché par cette
arrivée très importante de réfugiés en
2015 huit cent cinquante mille personnes
qui sont passées de la turquie à la
grèce moi je m'interroge toujours sur le
comment les gens peuvent ont pu quitter
ainsi la turquie qui est un pays très
policier très militarisée
donc je pense que monsieur erdogan à
jouer un instrument de chantage et qui
continuent de
de l'exercer et on est je crois je
trouve que les grecs ont fait preuve
d'une immense solidarité puis à ce refus
de doter de quotas de répartition de
certains états membres
oui oui je suis tout à fait d'accord ce
que vient de dire ma collègue
la grèce a vraiment donné des services
énormes dans cette phase très difficile
il faut donner plus de 2 de l'argent à
la grèce pour assurer que les conditions
dans les hébergements temporaires sont
vraiment humain chez nous ce qui est
incroyable dans cette histoire c'est que
alors que sur la crise des dettes
souveraines
il n'y a eu aucune solidarité de la part
de l'union européenne vis-à-vis la grèce
la grèce elle a fait preuve de toute la
solidarité dont elle était capable au
pire moment de sa situation économique
de cette vis-à-vis de l'arrivée des
migrants
la grèce qui dira en tout cas c'est
députés comme les autres membres de
l'union européenne le 26 mai nous en
reparlerons merci à tous les trois
devraient essayer aujourd'hui merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
nos différents sites lcpan public sénat
et rtbf.be bonne semaine à tous et à
très bientôt
[Musique]